thank you to finimize for supporting PBS
money is one of the oldest aspects of
human culture likely predating the
written word it's woven into the fabric
of virtually all human activity like
food family work religion and
celebration so it's not surprising that
there is a wide variety of unique money
Customs around the world some of these
may seem odd or superstitious but for
those who grow up with them they're just
a part of life they can be ceremonial
Traditions symbols of prosperity or
remembrance or even functional practices
that keep communities afloat but they'll
all make you realize how important money
is to humans not just economically but
psychologically and socially as well and
maybe they'll encourage you to look at
your own weird money traditions in a new
way
foreign
[Music]
stop is Africa Kenya to be specific
where there is a long tradition of
coming together to help community
members who are in need harambe a
Swahili word which means everyone
pulling together is actually the
official motto of the country and yes
that is where the meme-tastic gorilla
got his name R.I.P the word harambe can
also refer to an organized Community
event that raises funds or help for a
specific cause if someone in the
community is facing a significant
problem or life event they can contact
an elder family member or tribal leader
who will meet with other Elders to
determine whether the situation warrants
a harambe if so the word will go out to
friends family and co-workers who will
come together to donate money time and
emotional support to the person in need
kind of like an in-person GoFundMe maybe
you're not in financial trouble but you
still find it difficult to save up money
for important life goals if so you might
be interested in the tradition of Susu
from West Africa and the Caribbean it's
kind of like an informal group savings
account a number of people agreed to
deposit a certain amount of money into a
treasury at regular intervals once the
total has reached a set goal the
entirety is given to one member of the
Susu and a new recipient is chosen this
cycle continues until everyone has been
paid out though they don't pay any
interest and you only get back what you
put in susu's offer group accountability
so they can be helpful to people who
have trouble saving or don't have
alternate access to a loan similar
Arrangements exist in Central and South
American communities where they can be
known as tandas kundidas juntas or
panderos however these Arrangements
typically don't involve a formal
contract or any regulation so you have
to be sure that you're saving with
people you really trust one of the
biggest community events in any culture
is the wedding so it's not surprising
that there are a lot of wedding Customs
that involve cash in Nigerian weddings
as the couple hits the Dance Floor
guests circle around showering money
over their heads in Filipino culture the
women attendees line up in front of the
broom to pin money on him while the men
do the same for the pride and Italian
Brides sometimes wear a satin bag for
guests to drop money in in Japan the
bride and groom receive cash gifts known
as gushugi in a special envelope called
goshugi bukuro which says how much and
from whom but you can't just put cash
from your wallet into the gushugi bukuro
the bills must be new and crisp most of
these Customs involve generosity within
a family or tight-knit Community but
many cultural Traditions look to expand
that to charity one of the five pillars
of Islam is zakat which means to purify
and it's essentially a call to donate
money to the needy how much and how
often can differ but it's usually around
2.5 percent of one's total wealth in
most Muslim countries zakat is voluntary
and up to the donor to decide who the
recipient should be but in others like
Pakistan Libya and Malaysia zakat is
mandatory and collected by state
representatives essentially like attacks
it functions not just to help those in
need but to reinforce the spirituality
of The Giver by donating a small
percentage of your wealth you purify the
rest of it in Turkey one way to fulfill
zakat is with a practice called
or hanging bread when you go to the
bakery you can pay for an extra loaf
which the vendor is supposed to set
aside for whoever can't afford to buy
one the act of Charity is considered to
be more powerful because the donor is
anonymous the Italians have a similar
custom known as cafe sospeso or
suspended coffee which originated in the
working class cafes of Naples if someone
had a good day they can pay it forward
with an anonymous free coffee to an
unknown person you may have seen this
practice pop-up in some America coffee
shops Superstition and money go hand in
hand in all cultures in China cash given
to Children during the Lunar New Year
shouldn't contain the number four as it
sounds a lot like death in Chinese and
is therefore considered unlucky the
Chinese also have a tradition of burning
fake money at funerals known as Joss
paper so that the souls of the deceased
will have good fortune in the afterlife
in Turkey it's said that sleeping with
gold in your hand will bring you wealth
and success in Greece an empty wallet is
considered bad luck so be sure to put a
bill or two inside before giving one as
a gift at Christmas time in England
puddings are often baked with a coin in
the mixture bringing Good Fortune to
whoever gets the piece with the coin in
it and of course here in America if you
see a penny on the street and pick it up
all day long you'll have good luck you
know the more we talk about these
different money Customs the more similar
they feel they all seem to relate to
family community chair charity or Good
Fortune yeah even though money is a very
functional tool you can see there's a
lot of human emotion tied up in it it's
a symbol for prosperity and happiness
and also the glue that holds families
and communities together oh I've got one
more really weird money tradition for
you apparently in some Western countries
they believe in a magical creature who
pays real money for get this children's
teeth
what not a joke when the child loses a
tooth they put it under their pillow
while they're sleeping and then this Elf
or Goblin or whatever sneaks in takes
the tooth and leaves money behind ew
what does it do with all those teeth I
don't know maybe that's the currency and
Nightmare land or something super creepy
yeah and that's our two cents thank you
to finimize for supporting PBS vitamize
is an app and newsletter that helps you
become a smarter investor in 10 minutes
per day delivering all the insights and
tools you need to make smarter financial
decisions the newsletter summarizes the
financial news of the day in just a few
hundred words focusing on brevity and
humor to make the world of Finance more
understandable you can spot under the
radar opportunities and tax stocks
personal finance that can help you
expand your portfolio for more
information please go to the link in the
description before you go we are looking
for your feedback each year PBS digital
Studios conducts an audience survey and
it helps us understand what you like and
what you want to see more of you also
get to help PBS pick new shows it only
takes a few minutes but your feedback is
extremely valuable to us there is a link
in the description thanks in advance
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
Patron
do you have an interesting money custom
we may have missed tell us about it in
the comments